foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
until we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones and
House of the dragon video in this video
we will be looking ahead at next week's
episode now that we're about halfway
through this first season this show is
about to be firing on all cylinders and
by the looks of this new trailer we
should see fireworks all throughout this
next episode now let's have a look at
what's going to happen this Sunday after
watching the last episode which was my
favorite thus far I'm very excited to
see where everything goes from here on
out if he saw episode 4 then you know
one of its main focuses was on runner's
marriage after viserys gave her the
option of finding her own husband he
eventually had to basically force her to
marry sir Lenor valerion before she
ended up doing something that might ruin
her name as you all know in the last
episode we saw raniera having some fun
with her Uncle Damon Targaryen as well
as her own guard sir Kristen Cole now I
don't actually mind her having some fun
but what I think doesn't matter her
father viserys as well as all the other
Lords and Ladies of Westeros would see
this as a stain on her name name and
virtue viserys wants to make sure she
gets married before she does any
irreversible damage the new episode will
focus on rhaenyra and leonor's Royal
Wedding their marriage Alliance will
resurrect the relationship of House's
Targaryen and valerion who are arguably
the greatest houses in Westeros as these
houses unite they will now have
dominance over the land sea and air
HBO's new video begins with us seeing
house valerion's incredible Fleet as it
makes its way to the capital of King's
Landing this should be the sea snake
making his arrival as he gets ready to
marry off his son in air Lenor valerion
later we will see viserys arrive on
driftmark the seat and home of House of
valerion when he does arrive and greet
with the sea snake this is when we will
hear him say he wishes to marry off his
daughter in air as he hopes to Herald in
a second age of the dragons with this
marriage Alliance House Targaryen would
be adding rhaenys Targaryen and her
dragon melees as well as her son Lenor
valerion and his Dragon sea smoke and
their already incredible Air Force we do
see these dragons flying in the air in
this new video this will be our first
official glimpse of rainey's dragon
melees who is also known as the Red
Queen for those of you that don't know
melees is a she Dragon who has red
Scarlet scales and Crest and horns that
are as bright as beaten copper her
dragon is considered to be one of the
swiftest dragons in all of Westeros in
fact it's said that she is faster than
Damon's dragon caraxis and the oldest
and largest living Dragon Veigar if you
have seen some of my other videos then
you know how excited I am to see this
Dragon because we will eventually see
her engage in one of the most amazing
dragon battles in all of A Song of Ice
and Fire now after watching HBO's new
video it looks as if their wedding will
have one hell of a ceremony in George RR
Martin's novel Fire and Blood it's said
that there was seven days of feasting
and jousting to celebrate rhaenyra in
lanor's wedding we've already seen a few
shots from this wedding and other
official videos from HBO now since it's
set in the Game of Thrones Universe we
know that a wedding without at least
three deaths is considered a doll affair
a tough Rocky wedding without at least
three deaths is considered a dollar Fair
the Lannisters and their regards
there's nothing
it's joking I'm the poor boy
Nera and lenor's wedding will be no
exception as I said earlier in the video
it looks like there will be fireworks
during the ceremony there will be an
eruption of fighting as Madness ensues
I'm thinking this might have something
to do with sir Christian Cole again in
Fire and Blood we hear about Sir Kristen
slipping into rhaenyra's bed chamber to
confess his love during that scene he
also offers to run off with her to the
free cities where he would swear his
sword to someone else it says raniera
declines the offer Rainier says that
she's meant to be more than a wife of
some sell sword and if he can so easily
forget his kingsguard vows then he would
most likely do the same with his
marriage vows I think we might see
something like this but when he realizes
she's getting married to Sir lanor
Valerian anyway maybe he flips out and
starts a fight at the wedding during the
seven days of celebrating reniera's
marriage sir Kristen does break harwin's
collarbone and shatter his elbow during
the melee it looks like they might have
him do this at the wedding instead sir
Kristen Cole also defeats Joffrey
lawnmouth who also happens to be the
lover of Rainier's new husband Lenor
valerion after sir Kristen smashes
Joffrey in the head with his Morning
Star he dies from the head injury six
days later once again it looks like they
might have him do some of these fights
at the wedding now sir Kristen will make
a lot of enemies for this even viserys
will be angry with him Alison on the
other hand isn't bothered by what he had
done and in fact this is when she will
decide to make him her own guard we've
even seen some evidence of this in HBO's
other official videos you can see sir
Kristen and Allison standing on the same
side here as they give Rainier a dirty
looks as you can imagine this will add
gasoline to the already lit flame that
is burning down raniera in Allison's
relationship right as it seemed like
they were about to be friends again
their friendship will be shattered for
good after this moving forward sir
Kristen will never look at her the same
again in fact this wedding might be one
of the last celebrations we see with all
of these characters in the same room
many of the relationships will be
covered after these events as we see the
health of viserys continue to fall we
will also see everyone start drawing
their lines in the sand as the new Lane
opens up for the Iron Throne if it
hasn't been obvious already viserys will
die very soon we even see Allison watch
him fall down in the video he might only
be around for a few more episodes and
once he's gone for good all hell will
break loose we hear Serratos farewell
before he leaves the city he lets Alison
know viserys will die very soon and when
that day is here aegon must be ready for
the Iron Throne he doesn't want it to
end up in the hands of rhaenyra or even
worse the man standing behind her in the
shadows Damon Targaryen in the last
episode viserys threw him out of the
city forcing him to go back to the veil
with his wife well it looks like Damon
has something else in mind we already
know he doesn't want to be there
especially with his wife Raya Royce so
it looks like he's going to make sure
she has an accident that will eventually
end her life as you can see Damon is
seen here dressed as a shadowy figure
then we see see the same figure again as
his wife is thrown from the horse this
is how he will get rid of her for good
in Fire and Blood it says Reya Royce
fell from her horse and smashed her head
on a stone then she lingered for nine
days before finally filling well enough
to leave her bed only to fall down and
die within an hour of rising it is
interesting to see how they're making
Damon responsible for the death we have
seen some of his brutality before when
he was cracking heads during his days as
the Lord commander of the city watch
those actions however can be defended
I'm not so sure about this he may be
seen in a whole new light when and if
anyone does find out what he had done
now I actually like that they're doing
this by making his character even darker
if you ask me this feels like the early
days of Game of Thrones when the show
was at its height another interesting
thing about renera's wedding is it looks
like we might see mushroom during the
event now for those of you who don't
know mushroom is a dwarf who served as a
fool for viserys his son aegon and his
daughter raniera Targaryen he allegedly
wrote down the events that happened
during his days in their service
mushroom's testimony is filled with
stories of murders betrayals sexual
deviancies and many other salacious
claims all of which can be found in Fire
and Blood now if they do bring in this
character certain aspects of him will
remind you of Lord Tyrion Lannister
mushroom was a Dragonstone and were near
a service at the outbreak of the dance
of the Dragon so it would certainly make
sense if they do introduce him now I for
one am really hoping this is him he will
make all of his scenes far more
interesting and dare I say he will even
bring some much-needed levity to the
show once again it seems how so the
dragon will be delivering us another
amazing episode I've said it once and I
will say it again I think this show will
only continue to get better and better
from here on out I'm definitely looking
forward to seeing what this next episode
will bring let me know what all of you
think down below also don't forget to
subscribe so you can be the first to
know whenever I release my new videos I
will be making making five new videos
each week as always I want to thank all
of you for stopping by and showing some
love I hope all of you have a great day
I will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
foreign